what do you admire in the Name of Love a
body almost
I mean so much right like he has
he has driven the world forward in
important ways I think we will get to
electric vehicles much faster than we
would have if he didn't exist I think
we'll get to space much faster than we
would have if he didn't exist
and
as a sort of like
a citizen of the world I'm very
appreciative of that also like being a
jerk on Twitter aside in many instances
he's like a very funny and warm guy
and uh some of the jerk on Twitter thing
as a fan of humanity laid out in its
full complexity and Beauty I enjoy the
tension of ideas expressed so uh you
know I earlier said to admire how
transparent you are but I like how the
battles are happening before our eyes as
opposed to everybody closing off inside
boardrooms it's all yeah you know maybe
I should hit back and maybe someday I
will but it's not like my normal Style
it's all fascinating to watch and I
think both of you are brilliant people
and have early on for a long time really
cared about AGI and had had great
concerns about Aji but a great hope for
AGI and that's cool to see
um these big Minds having those
discussions uh even if they're tense at
times